Wine can be sophisticated, classy and robust
-- but in it's awkward teenage years it totally
has acne too.
[[MUSIC]]
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews -- Acne is
pretty gross.
It happens when a human pore gets clogged
and pus builds up inside that clogged pore.
Considering we have literally millions of
pores on our skin it's rather amazing we don't
have zits more often!
They can be caused by excess skin lipids or
accidental rapid cell division.
Normally, bacteria on the skin just hang out,
feeding on sebum we produce to lubricate our
hair shafts.
But when the follicle gets clogged more bacteria
show up and can cause inflammation.
The bacteria in question is called Propionibacterium
Acnes, and it's a completely normal thing
to have growing on human skin -- somewhere
it probably shouldn't be growing though, is
on the grapes from which we get the nectar
of the gods... wine.
And yet... scientists in Italy have found
human acne bacteria on wine grapes.
The kicker is, it's not actually the same
bacteria, it's an adaptation... basically
it evolved to live in a new place.
Propionibacterium acnes type Zappae lives
in the bark and pith of the grape vine.
It gets its name from Frank Zappa, because
the Italian scientists who discovered it were
listening to a Zappa album at the time.
The scientists know P. acnes type Zappae is
related to the human version, because there
are gene markers in its DNA.
They traced its genetic history to when they
were one species living on human skin, 7,000
years ago!
This aligns with the time humans were first
beginning to cultivate grape vines!
The discovery is INTERESTING because speaks
to microorganisms ability to adapt to new
environments and lifestyles to propagate themselves.
It's NOTABLE because it is the first time
ever, when a HUMAN bacteria jumped to a plant.
Chances are ancient peoples planted the grape
vines, and infected them with P. acnes.
The scientists believe the type Zappae has
since infected every grape vine in existence,
thanks humans.
Geez.
Most importantly, this infection probably
happened 7,000 years ago when grapes were
first taken from the Middle East.
While yes, there is acne bacteria all up on
those grape vines, it's not a food safety
thing.
They've been there for as long as we've been
growing them.
They're friends!
In comparison, humans have had acne for more
than 10,000 years!
King Tut had acne treatments in his tomb!
It's not going to hurt the grapes, but more
study is planned to find out how a human infection
crossed over onto plants...
How do you feel about this?
Need a drink?
Subscribe to our little video channel and
chat with us down below the video.
Or you can come find us on our Facebook page
-- 2.8 million and growing!
Thanks for watching DNews!